PROFESSOR: Let's get started.
Today we're really going
to take on folding polygons
into polyhedra in a big way.
We got started last time.
Today we're going
to do the real thing
with some tape and scissors.
Folding polyhedra.
It's pretty much the
last kind of folding
that we're going to be
talking about in this class.
We see linkage folding, paper
folding, unfolding polyhedra,
and finally, folding polyhedra.
So this is a, sort of, problem.
We're given some polygon.
We're not told where to
folder or how to glue it up,
necessarily.
We'd like to find,
is there some way
to glue this
boundary to itself--
I've drawn this picture
before, something like this--
in order to make a
convex polyhedron?
There's several versions
of this problem.
One is the decision version,
which is, I give you a polygon.
And I want to know, does it
make any convex polyhedron?
For the cross,
the answer is yes.
We will see examples later
today where the answer is no.
In fact, most of the
time the answer is no.
So given a polygon, can its
boundary be glued to itself?
And this is the
distinguishing feature
from origami is that's
all you get to do
and no multiple coverage.
You want exactly
that surface to be
folded into convex polyhedron.
And today's lecture is going
to be mainly about mathematics
for solving this problem.
The next class will be
algorithms for solving
this problem.
So we need some mathematical
tools, some cool geometry
stuff by a Russian
geometer called Alexandrov,
from the '40s.
And that's what we'll
be talking about today.
Then we'll see how that turns
into an algorithm next class.
Decision is nice.
But of course, we'd like to
actually find these gluings.
I want to actually know that
this guy folds into a cube.
So there's the
enumeration problem,
which is list all the
gluings and all the foldings.
And there's also the more
mathematical combinatorial
problem, which is,
how many can there be?
And we'll start
addressing that today
by showing that there
can be infinitely many.
There can be continua.
For example, this
polygon, this rectangle,
can fold into infinitely
many polyhedra.
We'll prove that today.
We won't do all of them.
But we'll one of them, I guess.
So that's makes this listing
all of them a little bit
difficult, when there's
infinitely many.
But it turns out they'll
fall into some nice classes.
We'll be able to
characterize that
at the end of today's class.
And so this problem is
actually well defined.
They're a finite number
of distinct classes.
And you could list them all.
There can actually
be exponentially
many of those classes.
But most the time,
it's polynomial.
That'll be more next class.
These are the sorts of problems
we're interested in folding.
Now, one natural
question is, why am I
restricting myself to convex?
And one answer is, well,
that's where most of the work
has been done.
But there is some nice
work on the nonconvex case.
So let me tell you about that.
So for nonconvex-- or
where you don't care about
whether the result
is convex-- you just
want it to make some polyhedron.
You can show it's
always possible.
What this means is if
I'm given some polygon,
and I glue up the
boundary somehow--
and this result
even holds if you
don't glue up all
of the boundary.
Because then we're no longer
trying to make a convex thing.
For example, I could
glue up all the boundary,
as long as the way that I glue
things is orientable-- I don't
put twists in an unresolvable
way, in these gluings--
then you're golden.
So you need that the surface
is orientable or has boundary.
So this is posed as an
open problem in our book.
And then we
discovered, this year,
that it was already solved
in 1960, but in Russian.
And then, it was only
translated in 1996.
We still should have
known about it in '96.
But we finally
realized that they
didn't talk about
folding or gluing.
They were talking about
realizing polyhedral metrics,
which is the language we're
going to translate to soon.
But our bad.
And I think this is a
pretty complicated result.
So we're not going to
talk about it here.
But it's interesting.
I'd like to learn more about it.
So it's by Burago
and Zalgaller, I've
used others of their theorems.
So it's funny I
didn't know this one.
In some sense, the
decision question
isn't interesting for
non-convex polyhedra.
So by restricting
the convex, saying,
I want to make
convex shapes, this
becomes an interesting problem.
And it leads to lots of cool
mathematics and algorithms.
And that's what we're
going to talk about.
So I want to talk about
this guy, Alexandrov.
Not really the guy, but the
mathematics that he did.
And we're going to appropriate
his name a little bit
and talk about
Alexandrov gluings.
This is a term that we made
up, obviously he didn't.
You don't usually make up your
own terms named after yourself.
We'd like to know which
gluings are valid.
We're not going to think about
where the thing is creased,
how to fold.
We're just going to focus
on the gluing for now.
What makes a gluing valid?
Well, one thing that we
talked about last time
is that once you have a
gluing, in this picture,
you can compute shortest paths.
You can compute the shortest
path from this vertex
to this vertex.
But here, it's a straight line.
There's probably
another path that
goes around a different way.
Last time we did the shortest
path from here to here.
And it was some
complicated thing.
I won't try to do it again.
But you can compute
shortest paths
once you know what's
connected to what.
So this defines what
we call a metric.
We're going to learn
something about that.
Polygon plus gluing
induce a metric.
Metric just means it tells you
how far different points are
from each other.
And we can compute that metric
by computing shortest paths.
I'm going to start
abstracting a little bit away
from polygon plus gluing
and just think about,
there's some surface
that, in your mind,
it's not really
geometric thing entirely.
But locally, you
understand the geometry.
If you're at some
corner, you can
understand what other
vertices are near to you
and how to walk around
on that surface.
So locally, you understand the
metric and how it's laid out.
When you're at this
corner, you know--
and let's say I glued this to
this-- that your curvature is
90 degrees, that there's 270
degrees of material there.
And you could go any one of
those 270 degrees of directions
from there.
So that's the sense in
which we have a metric.
Now, there are three things
that this metric should satisfy
if we want to make
something that's convex.
Any suggestions?
AUDIENCE: Less than
or equal to 360.
PROFESSOR: Less than or equal
to 360 degrees of material
an any point.
Yep, that is what we
would call convexity.
It's really a local convexity.
All points have 0 or
positive curvature.
That's the way I would say it.
Remember, curvature
was 360 minus some
of the angles at the vertex.
So this is the same as saying
you have, at most, 360 degrees
of material any point.
This is obviously necessary.
And the point is, you can
evaluate this just knowing
how things are glued together.
You don't need to
understand 3D geometry.
It's a local property.
And certainly necessary
if we're going
to try to make a
convex polyhedron.
Anything else?
They get less obvious
from here, I guess.
Any topologists?
AUDIENCE: You
shouldn't have holes.
PROFESSOR: Shouldn't have holes.
Right.
So I should definitely
glue everything together.
It's sort of implicit
in this statement
but not totally explicit.
And there's a little
more than that.
Not only should everything
to glued together,
but for example, if I glued
this edge to this edge
and I glued this edge to this
edge-- something like that.
That's probably not
going to work out.
Crossings are bad.
And what's really going
wrong there is the topology.
If we're trying to make
something that's convex,
it better be
topologically a sphere.
So that's the third condition.
And this is, again,
something you
can figure out just by
looking at the local metric.
This is a property
about metrics.
In their case of
polygons plus gluings,
it's really easy
to figure out when
this is the case, which is that
the gluing should be complete,
as you were saying.
You shouldn't leave
anything blank.
Everything gets
glued to something.
And it has no
crossings that will
be equivalent to being
sphere like, in our case.
The other property
actually always holds.
So it's no surprise that
you didn't think of it.
But if you want to think
a little more generally,
this a key property we're
using that we started
from a polygon, not some
smooth curve thing, which
is that only a finite number of
points have nonzero curvature.
If we want to make a polyhedron
with a finite a number
vertices, well,
these are going to be
the vertices, all the points
with nonzero curvature.
So there had better be a
finite number of those.
Now, when we start with
a polygon and just glue
some finite set of
segments to each other,
that will happen automatically.
But it's a property we're using.
So these three
properties together
are what I'm going to
call Alexandrov gluing.
If you satisfy all three of
these, you are Alexandrov.
And now, we have a cool
theorem about Alexandrov
gluings is called
Alexandrov's Theorem.
He had a lot of gluings,
but this the one
we use a lot in this field.
Originally proved
in 1941, I believe.
Then finally, his big
book about convex surfaces
was translated to English
in 2005, pretty recent.
But we've been reading other
translations, and so on,
to understand this theorem.
I guess I'm not using
Alexandrov gluing here.
But we have a
convex, polyhedral,
and topologically sphere.
Take any one of those things.
Then it's realized by a
unique convex polyhedron.
So this is basically the answer.
And from our perspective, it's
like , yeah, yeah, polyhedral.
Yeah, no crossings.
But really, the
central constraint
that we have to worry
about is convexity,
that we never glue
together too much material.
As long as you don't glue
together more than 360 degrees
material at any
point, then that thing
will realize a unique
convex polyhedron.
It's pretty cool but surprising.
The uniqueness should
not be surprising,
because we proved
that last class.
I can remind you briefly.
We proved Cauchy's
Rigidity Theorem,
which is not quite the same.
And then we said, oh, yeah, if
you have some convex polyhedron
metric, you don't
know necessarily
know what it looks like in 3D.
But you can compute
all shortest paths
from every vertex to
every other vertex.
And then however you
try to fold that thing,
every edge is a shortest path.
That's just a fact
about polyhedra.
The edges must be some subset
of these shortest paths.
So you think of this
as a convex polyhedron.
And then Cauchy's
Rigidity Theorem
says, there's only
one convex realization
of that thing with those edges.
And Cauchy allows some of the
edges to be flat like this.
So there will only be one
way to embed that in 3D--
at most one way.
The surprising thing
is that there actually
is one way that you can
realize-- I'm just thinking
totally locally in
this kind of gluing--
and yet, as long as
I don't glue together
too much material at any point,
I get a convex polyhedron.
With the usual gluing here,
without these crossings,
I get a cube.
No surprise, and it's unique.
But there are other ways
to glue this polygon.
We saw them, actually,
in Lecture 1--
I'll show them
again next class--
that can make other
convex polyhedra.
Let me give you a little
idea of the proof.
This is going to be a
pretty high-level sketch.
But I'll tell you the
combinatorial part.
And then there's the
topology analysis part
that's a little less obvious.
We've already proved uniqueness.
I want to look at existence.
And we're going to use induction
on the number of vertices.
And remember, vertices
are well defined.
When I say vertex
here, I really mean
point of nonzero curvature.
We know there's
finitely many of them.
Call the number n.
And we're going to try to
simplify our polyhedron
and reduce the number vertices.
But there's lots of ways
to do that with polyhedra.
But here, we don't
have a polyhedron.
We have this kind of abstract
polyhedron in Never Never Land.
We know how to walk around
on the surface, locally.
But we don't really
know any 3D geometry.
So is this a crazy idea.
Before we get to
the crazy idea, I
need an important fact, which
is total curvature, if you
sum over all vertices,
is 720 degrees.
This is actually true, even
of nonconvex polyhedra,
as long as you have something
homeomorphic to a sphere,
topologically a sphere.
Total curvature is 720.
This is actually why it's
useful to talk about curvature
and not how much angle is
coming together at a point.
So obviously, we've got zillions
of points with a curvature 0.
Those don't count for anything.
But then, somehow this thing
has to wrap around a sphere.
And you can compute the
curvature of a sphere at 720.
And this has to match that.
I can't give a lot of intuition
for this, but it's true.
And it's kind of powerful.
It says you can't have
very many sharp vertices.
If I have a super-sharp point
in my convex polyhedron,
it has a curvature close to 360.
It's going to be
260 minus almost 0.
I can only have two of
those in any polyhedron.
Now, with a
nonconvex polyhedron,
I can have negative
curvature to compensate.
And so then, I can have lots
of spikes, like an our witch's
hats, where we had four spikes.
But for convex, I don't
have any negative numbers
to compensate with these
big positive numbers.
So I can only have two spikes.
We're going to use that
a lot today, this fact.
It's called Descartes Theorem.
You may have heard of Descartes.
Nowadays, you prove
it in other ways.
But we're not going
to look at a proof.
We're just going to use it.
I'm also going to assume
that my polyhedron has
at least five vertices.
Or really, my polyhedral metric
has at least five vertices.
If it has at least
five vertices,
in other words,
more than four, then
there will be some vertex
that has less than a quarter
of 720 curvature, in
fact, two of them.
Two vertices-- and I call
them x and y-- have curvature.
Call them alpha and
beta, less than 180,
which is one quarter of 720.
The average is obviously
going down as n goes up.
So when n is 5, I can get two
reasonably small curvature
vertices.
This is like saying, there's
more than 180 degrees
of material glued at
these two points So what?
Well, now I'm going
to do some surgery,
as topologists call it.
I have these vertices, x and
y, in this sphere-like thing.
There's some shortest
path between them.
I can compute that.
And now we're
saying that there's
a fair amount of material here
and a fair amount of material
here.
What I'd like to do is
slice the surface open along
that shortest path.
I've drawn it twice,
because I've cut it open.
There's surface here, surface
here, and a hole there.
And I'm going to glue
in some more material.
And I'm going to
glue in a triangle--
actually, two triangles
right on top of each other.
So that here, the edges
are glued together.
Back here, the edges are glued
together, here, they're not.
So you can see, this is
still topologically a sphere.
As you walk on to this edge,
you end up on the top triangle.
I can go around the back
to the bottom triangle.
And eventually, I will
get to the back edge.
And then I can walk like that.
Shortest paths
are not preserved.
But it's at least still
topologically a sphere.
I've slipped this open,
wedged in two triangles.
I get a new metric.
Now, I get to choose
what triangles I glue in.
And I'm going to
set these angles.
Ultimately, I'd like
this angle to be
alpha over 2 and this
angle to be beta over 2.
Remember, curvature is 360 minus
the sum of the angles there.
That means that's how
much extra material
you need to stick in
until that vertex is flat.
So if I stick in an
angle of alpha over 2
here, at this point, and
there's two copies of it.
Because there's the front
triangle and the back triangle,
Then I'll be wedging
in alpha, which
is exactly what it
takes to make x flat.
And this is exactly what
it takes to make y flat.
The result will be
I'd obliterate x.
It's no longer a vertex.
I obliterate y.
But I add this new vertex, z.
In that way, I remove
two vertices, add one,
which decreases n.
And then I can use induction.
Now, there's lots of things
to say why this works.
But this is the crazy idea.
It's the Alexandrov
induction, and it's useful.
If you want to
prove, for example,
that the star unfolding
doesn't overlap,
you use this induction also.
It's the only
proof that's known.
So why did we need
these properties?
Well, the biggest
triangle you could make,
something like
this, like we were
doing in witch's hats,
where this is almost 90.
This is almost 90.
This is x and y.
The biggest we can make
alpha over 2 is almost 90.
And the biggest we can make
beta over 2 is almost 90.
So we'd really like alpha
and beta to be less than 180.
But then there is a valid
triangle that does this.
Once you fix two angles, it of
course determines third one.
It might be very close to 0.
So z might have very large
curvature, but that's OK.
What else?
The other thing is, in what
sense could you induct?
And this is where I'm going
to be a little hand wavy.
Yeah, I've found some
other polyhedral metric.
It has one fewer vertex.
So by induction I know that
it's realized by a unique convex
polyhedron.
The how in the world
would I convert that
into a realization of
the original polyhedron?
And the answer is
continuity and magic.
The continuity is easy to see.
When I glue in this
triangle, I don't
have to just glue
in the triangle
with those final angles.
I could actually glue in a
very tiny triangle initially.
And I could change these
angles continuously.
That makes me feel
a little bit better.
I start with something
that's very, very
close to my polyhedron.
Obviously, If I
could realize that,
I could still realize
the original, right?
It's almost the same, if I
glue in a tiny, tiny sliver
of a triangle.
That's not obvious,
but it's true.
And you vary it until the
point, where you actually
get something with
one fewer vertex.
Then you actually do
get a realization.
And then you continuously
morph it back to your original.
That's the idea.
I'm not going to
detail that idea.
It uses something called the
inverse function theorem, which
is a cool theorem
in real analysis.
But I think most of you
haven't had real analysis.
So you can read about
it if you're interested.
It's cool.
The main consequence
for us algorithms
people is that it's
non constructive.
It doesn't actually
tell you how to do this.
It just says, well,
by continuity,
it really ought to
work out somehow.
But we don't know how.
We've tried to make it
work out and failed.
While this does sort of prove
the theorem by continuity,
it doesn't actually
give us any idea
of how to find what
polyhedron we are realizing,
which is a bit frustrating.
And that was the state of
the art until four years ago.
Four years ago, these guys,
Bobenko and Izmestiev,
came up with a
constructive version
of Alexandrov's Theorem.
And I just want to sketch
an idea of how this works.
But the end consequence, which
is done in this class, I think,
as a class project
three years ago,
is that you get a pseudo
polynomial algorithm
for solving this problem.
So I'll jump ahead a little bit.
Running time, we
get-- this, again,
for amusement value-- 1891.
It's a good year.
I think I said, last time, that
n to the 125 times r to the 41
was my record.
Well, it's been surpassed.
I just forgot about it.
n to the 456.5 times r to the
1891, over epsilon epsilon.
Here is the desired error.
So you can make the error
as small as you want.
We can't do it perfectly.
But your running time increases
as the error goes down.
This is our usual feature size.
It's the longest length in
your input metric, let's say,
divided by the shortest length.
So that's a measure of how
tight the features are.
We had that before with
carpenter's rule stuff.
And n is the number vertices.
Obviously, this is
a very bad bound.
But the point is it's
pseudo polynomial.
It's a bad bound
for the same reason
that our last giant ginormous
bound was ginormous.
Because differential flow is
hard to get good bounds on.
See it's possible to
get some kind of bound.
But they don't usually represent
how fast the algorithm actually
is.
Again, this algorithm
is pretty practical.
There's an implementational.
I'll show it to you in a moment.
Maybe I'll show it
to you right now.
It'll be more fun.
It is available on
the web for free.
Try it out.
I assume this is a student
of Bobenko and Izmestiev
in Berlin, and he implemented
this program, Java.
So you specify a
polyhedral metric.
Now, that's the tricky part.
And especially,
it's tricky here,
because it has to
be triangulated.
But we would normally
do it by specifying
a polygon plus a gluing.
But of course, by computing
all shortest paths,
you can eventually make that
a nice triangulated thing.
So here I have a very simple
triangulated thing, namely,
a complete graph on
four vertices, which
makes a regular tetrahedron.
It doesn't look so
regular, because I
have a lot of perspective in
a small, narrow angle of view.
But that is a regular
tetrahedron, believe me.
Then I can change
the edge lengths.
Right now, they're
all one, so I should
be able to make one of
the edges longer, like 2.
I haven't tried this.
We'll see what happens.
I say, Compute, and it says,
Starting Calculations--
not my intended answer.
I like it to finish
the calculation.
That's why it prepared
some other examples.
I suspect it's not
the program failing,
but I've had some trouble
running it on this computer.
I think we have demo effect.
Finally, something
failed in this class.
It took a long time.
You'll have to try it online.
You can change the edge lengths
to all sorts of crazy things.
If you have very close
to degenerate situations,
it does tend to fail.
Because there's
some tricky issues
to deal with and
this floating point.
Oops, it might be
doing something.
Dare I try to open a file?
Here, you get to see my
organizational structure
or lack thereof.
Courses, Slides, 15,
and let's take Cube.
Exciting.
This is a cube.
It's not so obvious
that it is a cube.
But you set the edge links.
And a lot of these
are sort of diagonals.
And if I do it right,
maybe add some iterations.
It says, [INAUDIBLE]
successfully constructed.
You can see it, right?
My job is failing, I'm afraid.
Sorry about that.
Go away.
You'll have to try it at home.
AUDIENCE: It was there.
PROFESSOR: It was there?
Oh.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Wait, I
don't see a cube.
What did you see?
AUDIENCE: It was there.
PROFESSOR: It was there.
All right, you saw it.
It's like it ghost.
It's the left over
from Halloween.
Let me tell you a little
bit about how this works.
And you'll have to try
the program at home.
A crazy idea is we have
this polyhedron, which
we want to find.
It's a surface.
It's hard to think about
surfaces that live in 3D.
So I want to make it
more three dimensional.
And the way I
going to do that is
by thinking about the
inside of the polyhedron.
And say, well,
imagine it's convex.
So there's some point
inside the polyhedron.
Start with one point.
And then, I'd like to fill
the interior in between.
So the surface, as you saw--
we're assuming that everything
is initially triangulated.
We can do that by
adding shortest paths.
Well, if this triangle
is on the surface,
and this point is in the
center, the natural thing to do
is to make tetrahedra inside.
If I could find
the 3D triangles,
I could also find
the 3D tetrahedra.
So we're going to
do a harder job
of finding the 3D tetrahedra.
From that, we will
derive what the triangles
are-- easy enough idea.
Make your problem harder.
That often makes things easier.
How do we do that?
Well, for every
vertex up here-- call
it vi-- there's some distance.
This dashed line-- we're
going to call that ri.
That's really what we'd
like to figure out.
We already know the triangles--
we know their geometry.
That's given to us as
part of the metric.
We don't know how the
triangles are hinged,
with respect to each other.
That's the dihedral angles.
That's the tricky part.
But we're not going to
worry about that directly.
We're going to think about
these edge lengths, ri.
Because if I knew
all the ri lengths--
they're the sort of radii
from the center point-- then
I'd know all the edge
lengths of the tetrahedron
that uniquely determined
the tetrahedron.
If I do that for
all the tetrahedron,
there would be a unique
way to glue them together.
And I would get the answer.
So I really just
need these ri's.
What I'd like to
do is characterize,
when are the ri's valid?
And there's a few conditions
to make them reasonable.
The first thing, I guess I
didn't even write in the notes.
You might call it
sanity, which is
that these are
real 3D tetrahedra.
I'm not going to try to
characterize when that's true.
It's some function on the ri
lengths and existing lengths.
But I always want these to
correspond actual tetrahedra.
The trouble is, they might
not fit together right
to make 3D polyhedron.
So I won't really have to
worry about this condition.
The next condition-- what
do I call it-- is convexity.
This will also be kind of easy.
What I want is that the
outside surface is convex.
Now, if you look at the outside
surface, what we really want
is that one of these edges,
on the outside surface,
bends the correct way.
So when will that be true?
Well, I'm going to look
at the two triangles
next to that edge.
That defines two tetrahedra
that share a face.
And if I knew what
the ri's where,
I'd know what those
tetrahedra are.
And what I really need is
that if I look at the angle--
I'm going to draw this
a little bit thicker--
this dihedral angle
between-- it's hard to draw.
If you look at
this edge, there's
two tetrahedra glued there.
So there's some
solid dihedral angle
of tetrahedron glued at that
edge from this tetrahedron.
And there's some
angle over here that's
glued to this edge
from that tetrahedron.
I want the sum of those
two dihedral angles,
the total material there, to
be less than or equal to 180.
That is, the sum of
those angles is really
the dihedral angle
along this edge.
If it's less than
180, it'll be convex.
It's hard to draw,
but very intuitive.
This is also pretty easy to get.
You can set the ri
so that that's true.
The hard part is
looking at a vertex.
You think about a vertex.
It has a whole bunch
of triangles around it.
From this vertex to the central
point, which we usually call p,
if you look at that edge-- I'm
not going to try to draw it--
there's, in this
case, five tetrahedra
glued around that edge.
The total dihedral angle
of those five tetrahedra
ought to be exactly 360.
If these tetrahedra are going
to fit together and make
a solid thing-- and this we
call the reality constraint.
I'm not usually bound by
the reality constraint.
In fact, we will
relax it a little bit.
But we would like that the
sum of the dihedral angles
around some edge from
P to vi equals 360.
This is the hard
constraint to get.
Reality is tough.
Sanity, convexity, easy.
I guess I shouldn't
kill this yet.
So let me tell you a little
bit more about how we get this.
I'll just tell you
some of this stuff.
The first thing we do is
get sanity and convexity
and forget about reality.
Reality is overrated.
To do that, we actually
need two things.
One, is we need a
triangulation of the surface.
We're presumably given
some triangulation,
but that one might
be hard to work with.
And the answer is,
to start out, it's
nice to use Delaunay
triangulation.
How many people know about
the Delaunay triangulations?
They're nice triangulations.
And you can define
Delaunay triangulation
in an implicit
surface like this.
I won't do that here.
But it can be done,
and it can be computed.
One of the innovations
in this paper
was to actually show
how to compute it
in pseudo polynomial time.
It's not too hard.
It's just shortest paths.
Then, it turns out, if you
start with that triangulation,
and you let all the ri's be
really, really big, close
to infinity, then sanity
and convexity hold.
So I guess intuition may
be like witch's hats.
I don't know.
You're making these super-sharp
triangles, tetrahedra.
And it will work.
Now, it'll make
everything big and equal.
And so reality will be violated.
But sanity and convexity
are OK, and that
will be your starting point.
So now the crazy
idea is to fix it.
I'm going to define
a kind of curvature
around each edge, around that
center line from p to vi.
That's the sum that we
wanted to be equal to 360.
And now I'm just
taking 360 minus that.
That's the deficit.
This is how much we're off by.
So we have some starting point.
And it turns out the Ki
will be positive, I believe.
And we want to make Ki
evolve with time, so that it
is 1 minus t, times
the initial Ki.
So we start at times
0, with the solution
where all the ri's are large.
So we're staying in
convex, and we're
going to be staying in
convex from then on.
And then, if we could do this,
we would start at t equals 0.
This is 1 times the original
curvature at every edge,
so it's a problem.
But at t equals 1, at time
1, when this is finished,
we will get 0 times
whatever we had.
So all of these numbers
will magically go to 0.
And then it adds up to 360.
It's not obvious that
this works, but it does.
It defines a differential flow.
And those who know
differential equations,
this will look pretty.
This is partial
differential equations
to make it a little
more exciting.
This is a kappa and
inverse and phi.
What was phi?
I'm forgetting my own
notation, some initial value.
It should probably be r.
r?
We'll see.
All this is saying
is what I really
want is to evolve
kappas to go smaller.
I don't know how to do that,
because all I can do is change
the ri's.
That's the only thing I control.
The kappas are computed
as a function of the ri's.
There's a standard trick in
analysis-- or I guess, whatever
that is, calculus--
to rewrite things.
You get to control the ri's.
You want to control the kappas.
So you use this thing, which
is called the Jacobian.
It's a matrix.
But really, it says,
if I change ri,
how does that change kappa j?
It says that for all i and j.
So it's just a whole
bunch of different values.
They're really functions.
You invert that
because you really
want to know how--
I want to change
the ri's in order to
affect the kappas.
So you write this
differential equation.
And you just follow your nose,
and it tells you what to do.
I'm going to slide a whole
bunch of details under the rug.
The hard part is proving that
this relation is actually
feasible, that you can
change the ri's in order
to change the kappas,
no matter how you want.
This is equivalent to saying
that the Jacobian is never 0,
and it always has an inverse.
And that's hard to prove.
And in fact, they prove it using
the Inverse Function Theorem,
which is what we
were trying to avoid.
But hey, it's a
construction of sorts,
and it leads to
that implementation.
This, in some sense,
gives you an algorithm.
To turn it into an
actual algorithm--
as we did in this paper, which
appeared last year-- you need
to make this proof a little
bit more constructive,
a little bit more
algorithmic, let's say.
You don't just want to prove
that this Jacobian is never
zero 0 and that it
always has an inverse.
You need to prove
that it's actually
always at least some epsilon.
It's bounded away from 0,
and same for the inverse.
Instead of using
inverse functions there,
and we're totally
constructive, we just
look at second derivatives
and bound those.
We get a really awful
bound, which is this one.
But we do get an explicit
bound on how long, essentially,
the algorithm is implemented
and the applet takes.
So, a high-level sketch,
but it gives you an idea.
This is pretty new stuff.
Questions?
I want to move on to more
fun topics, let's technical,
I should say.
So that's Alexandrov's
Theorem algorithms.
In theory, there's
now a computer program
that will tell you
how to fold something,
as long as we have
an Alexandrov gluing.
So it has to be polyhedral.
That's pretty much for free.
It has to be convex.
That's the interesting part.
It has to be a
topological sphere that
is just non-crossing.
So let's think about gluings.
We know that as long as
we find a good gluing,
it corresponds to something.
We know that something's
a little hard to find.
But we'll see how we
find them in practice.
It's kind of fun.
We talked about the
decision problem.
Is it possible at all
for a given polygon?
So here's a polygon where
it's not possible at all.
It's kind of fun-- ungluable.
I should make that sharper.
So this is a polygon.
This is the material.
I want to glue it
into a convex shape.
I claim it's not possible.
The reason is, think
about this vertex.
What could get glued
to that vertex?
It has to be less than 360.
Right now, it's less than 360.
It's that much material.
Could I glue any other
vertex to that point?
No.
Because all the other vertices
have at least 90 degrees
of material.
This one has even more.
But all them have at least 90.
And there's less
than 90 remaining.
So no other vertex
could be glued there.
The other possibility, it
doesn't have to be a vertex.
It could be a point in
the middle of an edge.
But that has 180 degrees.
That's way too much,
so nothing fits there.
Therefore, I have
glue like this.
This is what we call zipping.
I zip those two
edges to each other.
Now, they happen to be
exactly the same length.
Therefore, this vertex
gets glued to that vertex.
But that's not allowed,
because there's more than 180
and more than 180
here-- contradiction.
So that's it.
This can actually happen a lot.
Let me formalize that.
So we could look at what you
might call the generic case.
And I won't call it
the generic case.
But there's a back reference
there, all the linkage stuff.
I can explicitly think
about the random case.
Suppose you choose all
the lengths of your edges
and all you angles at
random in your polygon.
You get some messy thing.
But the point is,
around half the vertices
will be reflex
angle, more than 180.
And those are kind of troubled.
Because if you have a
reflex vertex like this,
in particular, you can't
glue the middle of an edge.
Because that has 180.
You can only blue
convex vertices
that have some smaller
angle into there.
Otherwise, use zip, and
zipping would be like this.
So, what do I want to say?
Yeah, I see.
Right, cool.
Before I get to zipping,
maybe I glue some convex angle
in there.
It's the same kind of analysis.
Maybe I glue some convex angle.
But if the angles
are chosen at random,
I'm not going to get lucky
and completely flatten out
the vertex.
It won't disappear.
That would be too
much to hope for.
So most the time,
I'm going to glue
in-- maybe I glue
in some material.
Then I glue in some more.
At some point, I get stuck.
I can't glue anymore in, or
I decide I don't want to.
At that point, I must zip.
This is a rather
ambiguous notation.
But zipping, I want to glue
this edge to that edge.
Well, how long can
I zip them for?
Well, let's say I zip them.
At any moment here,
I'm gluing a 180 degree
angle to another
180 degree angle.
I can't stop zipping
once I start.
Because there's nothing else
that could fit in there.
So I've got to zip
until I get to a corner.
There's going to be some
corner, some vertex, that's
glued to some point.
Now, is it going to
be glued to a vertex?
Well, that would
be awfully lucky.
That would mean
that these two edges
have exactly the same length.
That's not going
to happen randomly.
One of these is going to
be larger than the other.
Now I'm gluing some angle
to a 180 degree angle.
The result is another
reflex vertex.
This will keep going.
And you'll never finish.
So this is a bit hand wavy.
But you can see the textbook
for more formal argument.
I have it here.
I'll finish it for you.
This would be fine if
this vertex is convex.
This is less than 180.
But actually, with
probability 1/2,
it's going to be
a reflex vertex.
And then you're screwed, because
now you have more than 180
gluing to 180.
That's more than 360.
So you don't even have to
go all the way to the end.
Immediately, after
the very first zip,
with probability
1/2, you'll fail.
I you have n vertices, and
half of them are reflex,
a quarter of them
are going to fail.
So that's plenty, as long
as n is bigger than 4.
For n large, you're going to get
exponentially high probability
that this fails.
Most of the time, if you're
choosing random polyhedra,
random polygons,
you can't glue them.
So you've got to be clever,
choose some nice polygons.
It's actually not that hard.
Like the cross, if you
just glued together
a bunch of unit squares,
it'll go into something nice
probably.
Or here's another great, class.
Convex polygons.
Convex polygons do
always glue to something
using something called
perimeter having.
What to do, basically,
by having the perimeter.
I have some convex polygon.
I'm going to choose any
point on the boundary.
And then have the
perimeter from there.
So I walk equal distance,
all around this thing-- equal
speed, I should say.
Something like that.
This is x.
This is the antipodal point, in
terms of measuring perimeter.
Now I zip.
So I'm going to
glue this to this.
I'm going to glue this to this.
I drew all those marks.
I was planning ahead.
Can you tell?
I was trying to make all the
segments the same length,
so that I could properly glue.
Something I've never
really said about gluings,
but you should always glue same
length things to other things.
Segments.
OK, there we go.
There's a gluing.
There's no crossings
in that glowing.
You can check.
Its Alexandrov.
It is convex, because
what do I glue to what?
Well, here, maybe
I'm going this vertex
to the middle of this edge.
But it's a convex vertex.
So that's OK.
Everything looks like that.
You're always gluing some
vertex to some other edge.
And all the vertices are convex.
So it will be less than 360.
Maybe, if you got lucky, some
edge will glue to some edge.
But that's still barely OK.
So for convex polygons,
it's always going to work.
Let's try it out, shall we?
I don't want to use this page,
because I'm not done with it.
We'll take page one,
make a convex polygon.
I don't want to make
it too complicated.
I'll spend a lot of time taping.
You an try this at home with
your own, favorite convex
polygon.
Here's a convex polygon.
And now, we're going
to pick a point.
Do I have a good
point written here?
Let's try here.
See that point, purple?
Now we are going to zip.
So take this.
I glue those edges together.
I don't have glue, or
glue takes a while to dry.
So we're going to use tape.
Ta-da.
Now, we have to
glue a little more.
I'm going to pretend
those just met.
Eh, it's a little ugly.
Man, couldn't I have
chosen something
a little more degenerate?
Here, it really does
work in the random case,
which is fine, as long as
I was restricted to convex.
Now, we're going to
If you brought tape,
you can try yourself.
Tape a little more.
See, it's already making
a convex polyhedron.
It's like magic.
For a long time, we've
tried to turn this process
into an algorithm.
Because it looks
pretty good, right?
But we have not been
able to formalize this.
This differential flow does not
really follow our intuition.
Now, I'm going to glue
these are edges together.
This is when I wish
I had three hands.
A little more.
And there, we've computed
the antipodal point.
In theory, you would zip that.
But I'm going to leave
it open to give myself
some maneuverability here.
So you puff it out a little.
It will be kind of
round and convex.
Now, that's not
quite a polyhedron.
But this is a polyhedral metric.
And Alexandrov's
Theorem says this
should make a unique
convex polyhedron.
And with a little bit of
practice and thinking about it,
you can derive that actually
this must be an edge here.
It's more of an intuition thing.
See, it looks like this
really wants to bend there.
So that must be an edge.
This one looks like it
must be an edge here.
This gets a little hard to do.
But this is how we
used to do them.
Wow, this probably
still is how we do them.
I haven't done a lot
of these in a while.
It looks like
there's an edge here.
Oh boy, something like that.
Here there already is and
edge, kind of convenient.
Here there's an edge.
I'm just folding point to point.
I'm almost triangulated.
I've got a nice line there.
It's starting to look
like a polyhedron.
There's a couple missing.
This guy probably has
a diagonal somewhere.
I would guess here.
And on the bottom, there's
a diagonal missing,
I would guess, here.
One of them is going
to make it reflex
when the other one
will make it convex.
You can experiment.
Then you unfold, ideally,
and make a better version
of this with more properly
drawn lines and then refold it.
And I bet you it makes a
beautiful convex polyhedron.
So this is the
experimental approach.
And this gives you a hands-on
feel for Alexandrov's Theorem.
Like that.
Yeah, almost.
Believe me, it's a
triangulated convex polyhedron.
Gorgeous.
That's how it works.
And you can try for your
own convex polyhedron
where you're
guaranteed not to fail.
Now, you prove some nice things
about these perimeter havings.
In particular, I had this
flexibility of where I started
and where I ended.
And I could move those
points continuously.
There's infinitely many
choices for x and y.
And certainly, there's
infinitely many gluings.
I can just keep moving x and
moving y correspondingly.
There's a whole
continuum of gluings.
They're all different.
They all generate
different polyhedra,
if you think about it.
Because if you think
of x being very close.
x is definitely going to be
a vertex of your polyhedron.
Because you end up gluing
this part of the edge
to this part of the edge.
So you have 180 degrees
of material there.
That's a vertex, less than 360.
And this is also a
vertex, let's say.
Look at the nearest
neighbor to x.
Here is a distance
between two vertices.
It's the shortest path.
If you make x very
close to the vertex,
it will be a shortest path.
And you're setting
that to infinitely
many different values, a whole
continuum, very close to 0.
If you look at some polyhedron
that this thing realizes,
it has whatever, n vertices.
You look at the n squared
different shortest paths
between them.
That's some finite
set of real numbers.
And here, I'm supposed to get
a continuum of real numbers.
Therefore, the set
of all polyhedra
that you are making in this
process is a continuum.
There's a lot of them.
Most of the things
you'll get out of this
are different polyhedra.
If I started with a
different x and y,
I'd get a slightly
different polyhedron.
It will change continuously,
but it will be different.
So this is the sense in
which, at the beginning,
I said there infinitely
many gluings.
Really, the only time
that they're infinite
is when you have a
convex polygon somewhere
embedded inside your polygon.
It doesn't have
to be at the top.
All right, where
do I want to go?
Here.
One way to think about
gluings is all these arrows
that are not crossing.
But it's a little bit
awkward to work with.
And next class we're
going to really find
algorithms to compute
these gluings.
And it's useful to have
another structure, another way
of looking and gluings,
called the gluing tree.
And the main idea is to
take your polygon, which
I'm going to explicitly shade.
Because you're
soon going to lose
track of where it is
if I don't shade it.
So that's the inside
of the polygon,
and there's outside space.
I want to turn this
whole picture inside out.
Think of this as
living on a sphere.
On the sphere, there's
some shaded region.
That's the material.
And then there's the rest,
the black of the blackboard.
If I look on the other
side of the sphere,
my perspective will be, I
have some convex polygon.
And the interior of the
polygon is on the outside.
This is a useful way of
thinking about things.
So there's my
polygons out there.
Now in fact, in a convex case,
this would be less than 180.
It's hard to see
that in this picture.
But just think of
it topologically.
Don't worry so much
about the geometry.
Now, what I'm trying to do--
it's a little easier to think
about, oh, I need to glue
this edge to this edge
and then maybe glue
up to whatever.
Maybe these were
the full length.
Then I'll glue this edge to
this portion of that edge.
So I still can draw my
arrows, something like that.
This would be a
parameter having gluing.
I can still draw
them, but now they're
on the inside instead
of the outside.
It's easier to see them.
And in particular,
I could actually
say, well, if I want to go that
edge to that edge, why don't I
draw them next to each other?
So it would look like this.
Then have these edges when I
draw them next to each other.
And then I have those edges
and then that edge and then
the little edges, except these
are actually the same point.
So it would look like that.
I think of these as almost
touching and then the material
still on the outside.
It's not looking so white
anymore, but you get the idea.
Well, that's a path.
In general, you get a tree.
So a gluing tree will look
something like this, maybe.
It's a double tree.
There's an underlying tree here,
and then you walk around it.
And the material
is all out here.
It's like that's
where you're gluing.
Now, this is actually
really intuitive to us.
It could be.
When we were thinking
about where to cut along
the surface of a
convex polyhedron,
at some point we said, well,
in a convex polyhedron,
we had all these properties
that, in the end,
said the cuts must be a
spanning tree of the vertices.
Every vertex must get cut too.
And you can't have any
cycles in the cuts,
because that would
disconnect the surface.
So where you cut was
a set of was a tree,
a set of edges forming a tree.
That's the cut tree, just
viewed from the other side.
That's where we want to glue.
Folding is supposed to
be exactly the opposite
of unfolding.
That's why the gluing
tree is a tree.
You could think about
some interesting things
like where are the vertices
of my polygon in that picture?
So here, I made all these
notches, but not all of them
were vertices.
Some of them were
the middles of edges.
So this one might be 180,
meaning it wasn't really
a vertex of the polygon.
It was the middle of an edge.
Obviously, if I
look at some vertex
where three corners are coming
together, if one of them
was 180 and another
one was 180, we
would not have room for a third.
At a degree 3 vertex
or more, it could have,
at most, one middle of an edge.
These guys, the
other remaining guys,
must be vertices of the polygon.
The middle of an edge
could be two 180s.
That's actually
the typical case.
If you look at one of these
gluings, most of the points,
it's the middle
of an edge gluing
to another middle of an edge.
That's what's happening
almost everywhere.
But you could also have some
180 gluing to some vertex.
But then it had better be a
convex vertex, less than 180.
You can go around
and think about what
all these situations are.
When there's a 180,
the remaining guys
had better be convex.
And their total angle had
better be less than 180.
What about the leaves?
This is a zipping place.
I was talking about zips before,
were you just locally join
the two incident
edges to themselves.
The leaves are
where zips happen.
Trees have leaves,
so zips happen.
Zip happens.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: This
angle, obviously,
will be less than 360.
It could be a vertex,
and then at some angle,
or it could be the
middle of an edge.
And then it will be 180.
That's what we had over here.
I chose one and
x to be a vertex.
But then, generically,
on the other side,
you're going to get
the middle of an edge.
And the example I did
in reality, both of them
were in the middle of an edge.
I'm going to make
special note of the ones
where we have
material like this,
and you end up
zipping like that,
we call this a fold point.
I don't know why,
but you fold at it.
So it's some shorthand.
So these are fold
points, the leaves that
are at the middle
of an edge, they're
a little special or
a little restricted.
Because how much curvature
is at that point?
180.
Fold points have curvature 180.
The total curvature is 720.
So I can't have more
than four fold points.
They're actually quite
rare, but they can happen.
Obviously, we had two of
them in these examples.
Can actually have four?
Yeah I think.
AUDIENCE: Could you
have [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I'm going to
draw an actual folding,
with creases and everything.
This is a blintz space,
for the origamists.
You fold like that.
You get a doubly covered square.
The gluing tree is
going to look like this.
You see that?
And it will be drawn
right on top of that,
and the actual
material is back here.
So this will be exactly
four fold points.
And just by luck, you have
these four 90 degree angles.
So there's no more
curvature there.
So yeah, you can definitely
get four fold points.
I don't know if you can
get a large examples four
fold points.
AUDIENCE: I think four fold
points means it'll be flat.
PROFESSOR: Four fold
AUDIENCE: So that's going
to be 0 curvature at that.
PROFESSOR: You're
going to have 0
curvature at every other vertex.
It's certainly implies
that you are a tetrahedron.
Because you only have
four vertices at all.
So yeah.
You might be able to start
with some complicate a polygon.
And then, everything
somehow disappears,
because all the angles match
up in a lucky way, like this.
But the polyhedron itself will
definitely be a tetrahedron.
I'm not sure if
it has to be flat,
but tetrahedron
is pretty simple.
So it's not so exciting.
Let me tell you
about rolling belts,
because they're really cool.
And then I think we're done.
A rolling belt is basically
an embedded, convex polygon.
And we saw that when we
looked at a convex polygon,
from the perspective of a
gluing tree, it was a path.
In general, I have a tree.
And I want to define
when a path in that tree
is like a convex polygon.
And like in the sense
that it can roll.
I could move x continuously
and move y corresponding,
and I'd always have
an Alexandrov gluing.
So it's like one of
these infinite families.
I'd like to detect those things,
and we call them rolling belts.
They're going to be a
path in the gluing tree.
Here are the
conditions you need.
The endpoints are
either fold points
or convex vertices, no reflex.
In that case, they
must be leaves.
And along that path, you
always have less than
or equal to 180 degrees of
material on either side.
This is pretty intuitive.
So you have some tree.
I'll draw a slightly more
general picture here.
And then, I look at some path
in that tree, maybe from here
to here.
Yeah, this was the
way I glued things up.
Now, imagine that I recut here.
Ideally, these are supposed
to be glued together.
But what if I separated, I
pulled just those parts apart?
I left these intact, all
the sub trees hanging off I
didn't touch.
And then I just
rolled that thing
like it was a convex polygon.
Which means, instead
of going here to here,
I'm going to glue this
point to this point.
I'm going to slide
this over a little bit.
Whereas before,
this point was glued
to itself-- that was the end of
the zip-- the new zip point is
going to be-- I can't tell,
everything's moving this way.
This point is going
to move up here.
And it's going to become
the new zip point.
Everybody here is moving
in that direction.
I just kind of roll that belt
along, and then I reglue.
And as long as it looks like
a convex polygon-- meaning,
as you walk around here,
the total amount of material
getting glued, like, here I
have two portions of material--
as long as that's, at most,
180 in total, I can do that.
Because if it's, at
most, 180 on both sides,
it will be, at
most, 360 in total.
So that's it.
And there's a separate
corner condition.
But all it's saying is that
it's, at most, 180 everywhere.
And then it's really acting
like a convex polygon,
but not in total, just in that
little subpath of the tree.
Turns out, this is
the only way to have
an infinite set of gluings.
All infinite goings will
look like rolling belts.
Now, there can be more
than one rolling belt
in a single example.
And this I can even build.
It's pretty simple.
I take a rectangle, and I
glue it into a cylinder.
Beautiful, what an
amazing cylinder.
But I'm not going to commit
to how the rest of the thing
is glued.
There's a cylinder.
What did I draw?
The gluing tree.
So initially, my rectangles
out here, imagine.
And I've glued--
what did I glue,
the shortage to the shortage?
So what I end up with,
in terms of gluing tree,
is I have these two edges
that are glued to each other.
And then I have this
big thing, which
I don't know how I
want to glue that yet.
I haven't decided.
So those loops are supposed
to get squashed into a tree.
And that's this
loop and this loop.
You can almost see this is a
weird projection of a cylinder.
A cylinder goes around
on the backside,
because all the
material is out here.
I'm totally free, what
I do with the top here.
It's a rolling belt.
Look, I can even role it.
It's great.
I can slide it around,
slide, slide, slide.
I can do this forever,
because it's cyclic.
And then separately, I can
slide this one however I want.
It doesn't matter.
At all times, I'm just
gluing 180 to 180.
And at the ends, I'm getting
to just single 180's.
Those are fold points.
Well, this one's not
technically a fold point
if I did it right at the vertex,
but it acts the same way.
So the gluing tree
is always going
to look something like this.
But each of these could roll.
So it could look like that.
It could look like it's even.
You get to slide this around.
So it's a double continuum,
a double rainbow.
In some cases, like this
one, when there are lines,
you actually get a flat thing,
which is kind of boring.
In all other cases, you will get
a convex tetrahedron, non-flat,
for this one example.
That's two rolling belts.
Now notice, to have
to rolling belts,
I basically had to
have four fold points.
Sounds familiar.
I can only have
four fold points.
So it seems like
maybe two rolling
belts is the most I can have.
Because each rolling belt--
if you roll a little bit,
it will have a fold
point on either end.
Two is kind of the
max, but only kind of.
You can do three.
Let's do three.
Three rolling belts.
I'm going to take this
example, the blintz space.
Yeah, let's look at this
example for a little bit.
I hadn't planned this.
The tree here, is this nice
four star, four-armed star.
And there's kind of a rolling
belt from here to here.
If I ignore the fact that there
are these things hanging off,
then I have, at most,
180 on both sides.
It acts just like a
rolling belt Also,
there's a rolling belt here.
They cross each other.
Crazy.
But in theory, it's
a little tricky.
They're not independent anymore.
I can roll one of
them however I want.
But if I roll that one at all,
I cannot roll the other one.
Because as soon as
you roll-- let's say
I roll the horizontal one.
It'll look like this.
They'll be if you roll that.
So these top and bottom
guys are no longer touching.
And if you try to make
this path a rolling belt,
it doesn't look so good.
Because here, this side,
there's more than 180.
It's going to have a 90 from
here and 180 from down there.
So that's no longer
a rolling belt.
Right now it is,
and I could roll
just the vertical one or the
horizontal one but not both.
But the point here is, you
can have rolling belts that
cross or overlap each
other, in general.
If we do the same thing
with a triangle-- in fact,
I think I'm going to make a
tetrahedron-- look at that.
Amazing.
Bring those three
points together.
The gluing tree looks like that.
This is the top of
the tetrahedron.
These are the other three
vertices of the tetrahedron.
It's a spanning tree
of the vertices.
I claim this is a rolling belt.
And therefore, so is
this and so is this.
So there are three of them.
Because at this point, well,
that was like a fold point.
There's only 180 degrees there.
As I walk around, here I
have two 60s going together.
That's less than 180.
And on the other
side, I just have 160.
So it's definitely less
than 180 on both sides,
all the way along this curve.
And by symmetry,
along all three.
So I can kind of get
three rolling belts.
They're not independent,
I don't think.
If I roll one of them, it
looks like actually maybe I
can keep rolling the others.
But this is the only way you
can get three rolling belts.
It turns out, four rolling
belts are impossible.
This is actually something
we proved in this class.
We've proved it six years ago.
So it's probably
even in the textbook.
I don't remember,
very simple proof.
If you have four rolling
belts, even if they overlap,
you have to have a lot of fold
points, at least four of them.
There has to be at least one
fold point per rolling belt,
because they have
different ends.
At least one end is different.
Here, we had three fold
points and three belts.
If we have four fold
points, at least four belts.
If you have four rolling belts,
at least four fold points.
Get the right direction.
We know there's only
four fold points.
So it's actually exactly
But as you were saying, when
you have four fold points,
there's really no more
curvature to go around.
In fact, this can't happen.
Because your four fold
points-- all the curvature
is at those four leaves.
Every other vertex must be
perfectly balanced, has to have
0 curvature.
And then things break.
It's not a very
convincing argument.
You imagine these fold points.
They're somewhere
in your gluing tree.
Maybe they're here.
In order to fit four rolling
belts, there's got to be,
on average, two rolling belts
coming out of every vertex.
And where they diverge,
it's a problem.
Because there has to be
basically 0 degrees of material
out here for them to roll
that way and to role that way
and have 0 curvature.
So it fails.
One rolling belt,
two rolling belts,
three rolling belts, no more.
So it's not that
complicated, in terms
of the infinite structure.
What's really interesting is
all the very combinatorially
different trees.
When I roll a belt,
not much changes.
It's just changing a
few of the lengths.
Next class, we're going to look
at how the trees themselves
can actually change
combinatorially and get bounds
on how many there or
how to compute them.
There's good algorithms
for it, all that stuff.
Still some open problems too.
That'll be next class,
which is on Monday.
No class on Wednesday.
That's it.